[Music]
give me the box
[Music]
[Music]
oh
what is this place the merit dimension
where i'm in control strange stop can we
please just talk about this parker don't
you realize that in the multiverse there
are an infinite number of people who
know peter parker is spider-man and if
that spell gets loose they're all coming
here look i know i get it but we can't
just send them home to die it's their
fate
you can't change that any more than you
can change who they are
oh what are you doing
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found
[Music]
when you out that spell where you wanted
everyone to forget the peter parker
spiderman
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
hello peter
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so scooby doo this crap you know all
this is kind of your mess i know a
couple of magic words myself starting
with the word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man it's
their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
there has to be another way there isn't
they're a danger to our universe
you know to take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
to have everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening they're starting to
come through
and i can't stop them
december 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale november 29th
spider monday
[Music]
you